for a daily cancellation today a short
one i went a little bit long in the
opening had a lot to say there so here's
an update on a story
that i've been following for months a
few others in media i've been following
it to not not very many others
this is this is one that the media
wanted us to forget about as soon as it
became obvious that the evidence wasn't
forthcoming to support the claim i refer
to althea bernstein
she's the biracial woman who claimed
that she was attacked by flame throwing
racist white men in madison wisconsin
the daily wire has the latest we talked
about you know earlier the
inevitabilities of life and well here's
another one
this this was inevitable madison
wisconsin police dropped an
investigation into alleged hate crime
against an 18 year old biracial woman on
friday
after finding little evidence to
corroborate the woman's story
althea bernstein told police in june
that she was attacked by a group of
four white men while stopped at a light
in madison
local police partnered with the fbi and
u.s district attorney scott blader of
the western district of wisconsin to
investigate the case so you've got
this is a federal and local
investigation they've all they've come
together to investigate this
the madison police department closed
this investigation on friday after
spending significant resources
looking into bernstein's claim
investigators were not able to establish
that the alleged attack ever occurred
this from the police the police
department said in a statement after an
exhaustive probe detectives were unable
to corroborate or locate evidence
consistent with what was reported
blader's office issued a similar
statement saying that the case could not
move forward for
quote lack of evidence like i said this
is shocking
shocking stuff it says in a statement
after a thorough investigation to the
events of june 24th
2020 including extensive interviews
exhaustive review of traffic and
surveillance video
expert review of digital and forensic
evidence federal investigators determine
that there is insufficient evidence to
prove that a violation of any federal
criminal statute occurred
that's the u.s attorney's office that's
what they said further further after
reviewing all available evidence
authorities could not establish that the
attack as alleged by the complainant
had occurred accordingly the federal
investigation into this incident has
been closed based on the lack of
evidence
now this is very telling bernstein's
family released a three-sentence
statement through the police department
thanking officials for their work
this is their statement althea bernstein
and her family
appreciate the detailed investigative
efforts by
all involved in the case althea's
injuries are healing and the support of
our community has been invaluable in
that regard
we continue to maintain our family
privacy and will not be granting
interviews at this time
okay so you notice how the family
they're not calling for more
investigation they're not chastising the
police for failing to apprehend the
dangerous gang of neo-nazis
again that again to remind you according
to bernstein accosted her at a stoplight
doused her with lighter fluid and then
set her face
on fire now this is the kind of thing
that'd be very easy to prove
it didn't if it did in fact happen there
are surveillance videos everywhere in
the city like they said they were
checking the surveillance videos
she said it happened in the middle of
the street at a stoplight
chances are the attack itself would be
on camera but even if it wasn't surely
there would be
footage of the white guys walking down
the street holding the lighter fluid and
lighter
unless these dudes rappelled down from
helicopters right into a specific spot
where no cameras can can can see it
carried out the attack and then used
like grappling hooks like batman to
escape
running across the rooftops short of
something like that
they would be on camera yet no cameras
noticed them
nor did any witnesses apparently notice
them
that's because it would appear they
never existed
and it's rather easy to not be noticed
when you don't exist
now it's it's a common saying that
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence
but actually sometimes it is and the
absence of evidence of the
torch-wielding
racists is very very compelling evidence
of their absence yet the police will not
be charging bernstein with a crime for
following
filing a false police report wasting law
enforcement resources
the media outlets that promoted this
claim will not print retractions or even
acknowledge the latest development
and the blm activists who use this case
as evidence of the alleged
scourge of white supremacy will not
apologize
or even give us so much as a you know oh
wait never mind
forget about that one there will be no
consequence of
any kind for any of the people involved
in promoting this story
a story that was obviously extremely
extremely
dubious from the get-go and all that
means of course is that we're going to
get more
dubious stories which is by design
so everyone involved here um
is of course rightfully needfully
canceled hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated